firm care but I can't help feeling that
the year in politics is off to a slow
start it's the 5th of January and I've
only still faced just one Chancellor of
the exchequer
but the truth is whoever is chancellor
or prime minister I'm under no Illusions
about the scale of the challenges our
country faces
in his speech today and over the coming
year Ikea and I will continue to set out
how we will rise to the challenges our
country faces because we know that our
country has great strengths in
industries from Life Sciences to
Professional Services to our cultural
Industries
in the Brilliance of our universities
and our entrepreneurs
and in the talent the efforts and the
decency of the British people
but we also know that these have been a
difficult few years
just this week the price of the weekly
food shop has reached record highs with
food prices up by more than 13 in a
single year
the courses we have faced have been
Global in origin but each time Britain
is uniquely exposed
and for that
the buck stops the successive
conservative governments they have run
down our economy trapping us in a cycle
of low pay under investment and weak
economic growth they have degraded our
public services and time and time again
they've elevated short-term political
interest over the long-term Goods of our
economy
ask yourself this
are you and your family better off than
you were 13 years ago
of our public services our schools our
hospitals and our transport working
better than they did a decade or so ago
frankly does anything in Britain work
today better than it does did 13 years
ago
and if to the answer to these questions
is no
I think you know that it is time for
change
we are at a Crossroads
we can follow the conservatives down the
path of managed decline
or we can change course
to build a Greener fairer and more
Dynamic Britain
it will take courage integrity and
vision
to repair the Damage Done and to unlock
Britain's enormous potential
a new approach to the economy with a
government that is pro-worker and
pro-business in the knowledge that each
is dependent upon the success of the
other
so when we invest in our green
transition when we extend security to
working people when we act to rescue our
Public Services once again from Tori
neglect
that will not only be because these
things are moral responsibilities
that they are that
but because it is a root it's a stronger
economy
a new way of doing politics
sweeping away the cronyism and the waste
of the last few years which saw billions
of pounds in public contracts handed out
to friends and donors of the
conservative party
pushing power out of Westminster and
into our Nations our regions and our
communities
and restoring public Trust
and a new kind of leadership
built on integrity
on stability
and only understanding that for our
country to succeed
the whole country must be able to play
its part
that is what Kia is going to speak about
today that is the leadership that he
offers
I am proud to serve as his shadow
Chancellor now I would like to say that
I'm introducing our next prime minister
but you never know how many tour is it
going to get through before the next
election
so let me just say that I will introduce
Britain's Next labor prime minister
kyostarma
thank you Rachel and thank you for all
your hard work for our part for our
country and happy New Year to everyone
here thank you so much for coming along
this morning and welcome to UCL here
East now this is a bit of London that
some of you are getting pretty familiar
with in the last few days so I've
decided that I won't tell the Prime
Minister where I'm going on holiday this
year just in case I find him there as
well
but look 2023 marks a new chapter for
Britain with a new king to be crowned in
may we must look forward with hope
I hope to flourish
Britain needs change
and I don't think anyone seriously
disputes that
it's the story of the country right now
amidst all the chaos is a growing
impatience for change for Real Change
lasting change National renewal
and yes as they've done throughout our
history
the British people are turning to labor
to provide that change
in 2022 they looked at us again and I
felt for the first time in a while
we could return their gaze with
confidence
changes we've made
of anti-Semitism of National Security
and NATO or making economic stability
the platform for everything we do has
restored a degree of trust
lead a foundation
and this year we've got to build on that
people know we care
they always know the labor party cares
and they can now see a party that is
both competent and compassionate
a party that understands what it means
to put service to the country first
College our task for 2023 is not to rest
on our Laurels we need to push forward
and rise to the moment prove we can be a
bold reforming government
show not just what the toys have done to
Britain but the Britain that labor can
build a fairer Greener more Dynamic
country with an economy that works for
everyone not just those at the top and
the politics which trust communities
with the power to control their destiny
a new government
and a new way of governing Britain needs
both
and with labor Britain will get both
that that's my message of Hope for the
new year
we're going to roll up our sleeves fix
the problems and improve our country
we can't keep expecting the British
people to just suck it up
not without the hope the possibility of
something better
don't get me wrong I'm under no
Illusions about the scale of the
challenges we face
houses that get burgle countless times
yet the police never come
hospitals if you can believe it putting
out messages begging patients to stay
away from a e
children going to school hungry
and it's not just the poorest who are
struggling
millions of families pensioners working
people people who've always kept their
heads above water are going without
decent food and Heating
cutting back on their holidays their
meals out Christmas presents all the
little things that make life more
enjoyable
now sometimes people say to me we'll get
through this
Britain's been through worse
and they're right
I grew up working class in the 1970s I
know what a cost of living crisis feels
like
the anxiety and yes the shame
of not being able to pay bills that only
months ago were affordable
our phone was cut off like this and by
the way that was it there were no
mobiles back then
we got through it
Britain will get through it
the problem is that's exactly what the
tourists are banking on they're going to
turn around in 2024 and try to claim
some kind of political credit for the
sacrifices working people are making
right now as if it's not their mistakes
people are paying for again
but at the heart of this cynical
politics
foreign
what we can achieve together
because
for all the challenges we face
I remain optimistic about our future I
believe in our country I believe in our
businesses I believe in our people and I
believe in our spirit
it was there in the coming together for
the funeral of Queen Elizabeth II
in the thousands of people who welcomed
refugees into their homes from Ukraine
and elsewhere
in the resilience of our retailers our
pubs and venues the creative Industries
fighting back for the pandemic
the Brilliance of key workers nurses
doctors teachers volunteers and carers
who got us to that point
it's in our love of sport
and our excellent at it
the double world champion cricketers the
commonwealth games that were a beacon of
diversity the lionesses who brought
football home
it's our universities our young people
the researchers in this building and
those like it are manufacturing genius
our superpower services our startups and
innovators the green entrepreneurs the
builders and retrofitters insulators and
Engineers who will bring us energy
Independence and cheaper bills the
scientists making Healthcare more
responsive saving more lives
and it's in our communities in towns and
cities like Burnley Wolverhampton
Grimsby and Swindon
where the people will tell you
in no uncertain terms
that they do have ambition for
themselves and their community
what they lack is a government that
shares their ambition
because all these achievements have
listed all that possibility is a
testament to our untapped potential
so this year
let's imagine instead what we could
achieve if we match the ambition of the
British people unlock their pride and
their purpose give them an economy of
politics that they deserve
this is crucial because economic change
must go hand in hand with political
change
we have an economy that holds potential
and the politics that Hoards power
and it's no coincidence no accident that
this leaves us with more Regional
inequality than anywhere else in Europe
they feed off each other and that's why
I say Britain needs a completely new way
of governing yes we need to use the
power of dynamic government harness
technology to drive through reform
convene a real industrial partnership
between business and unions
but all of that must be done in service
of a politics which trusts communities
I'm utterly convinced about this
the Westminster system is part of the
problem
now I came into politics late in my
career
I've run large organizations
institutions that had to serve our
country
and I've changed them all
including the labor party
that's why I came into politics eight
years ago
a new way to serve a new way to get
things done more opportunities to change
our country for the better
but I have to say
I haven't found much of that in
Westminster
yes there are good people of course
there are
many MPS share my determination to
tackle Britain's problems quickly
but as a system it doesn't work
you know sometimes I hear talk about a
huge day in Westminster
but all that's happened is someone has
passionately described a problem
and then that's it
nothing's changed the circus moves on
rinse and repeat
honestly you can't overstate how much a
short-term mindset dominates Westminster
and from there how it infects all the
institutions which try and fail to run
Britain from the center
I call it sticking plaster politics
sticking plaster politics and in a kind
of last minute frenzy it sometimes
delivers relief
but the long-term cure
that always eludes us
and it's at the heart of all the
problems we see across the country right
now
I'll give you an example
energy and the cost of living crisis
now thank heavens we have a price freeze
this winter
that Labor's campaigning in the summer
eventually brought the government to our
position and its senses
but truth be told the price freeze is
the perfect example of sticking plaster
politics
necessary of course
but nonetheless an expensive last minute
fix papering over cracks in our energy
security that have been on display for
years
now don't get me wrong nobody criticizes
the government for the effects of the
war in Ukraine
but the war didn't scrap home insulation
the war didn't ban onshore wind and the
war didn't stall British nuclear energy
the Tory government did that
and the store is the same with the NHS
and care and with all our Public
Services
the workforce and morale crisis has been
an iceberg on the horizon for years
low pay housing Child Care immigration
planning skills investment in technology
time and again it's the same pattern
you saw it yesterday from the prime
minister
commentary without solution
more promises more platitudes no
ambition to take us forward no sense of
what the country needs
13 years of nothing but sticking plaster
politics
it's why every crisis hits Britain
harder than our competitors
the only country of the G7 still poor
than it was before the pandemic
the worst decade for growth in two
centuries
7 million on waiting lists and Rising
that hasn't happened elsewhere
you know
one of the greatest privileges of being
born in Britain certainly for all of my
life
is knowing that if you get ill
if you have a serious accident you'll
get decent health care whatever your
circumstances
not every country has that and the
anxiety it causes is huge
it's why 11 years ago in the Olympic
Stadium a few hundred yards away we put
the NHS on display to the world
it's Who We Are
we can't let sticking plaster politics
destroy it I won't stand for that and
labor won't stand for that
that's why we've got a fully costed plan
for the biggest NHS training program in
our history
we'll tackle a capacity crisis with more
doctors more nurses more Health visitors
and will broker a fair pay agreement
that will transform the pain conditions
for every carer in the country give care
workers the respect and the status that
they deserve and help them drive up
standards in our care system that's a
massive part of the NHS crisis
I heard the Prime Minister yesterday
and he's still in denial about how we
got here
still too weak to challenge the vested
interests in his party that hold Britain
back
don't expect that to change
on planning on onshore wind on the NHS
not now not for the past 13 years not
ever
fundamentally the Tories don't accept
that to help working people succeed you
need Dynamic government government
driven by a strategic purpose
they don't see that the challenges we
face on climate change artificial
intelligence caring for an aging society
means a hands-off approach to our
economy and public services just won't
wash anymore
this is a real political divide
but it's not just Tory ideology that
drives sticking plaster politics
it's the whole Westminster system
no similar country puts so much decision
making in the powers of so few people
it's no wonder the problems of
communities up and down the country
don't get the attention they deserve
just think about it practically for a
minute
imagine Britain is a workplace
now the boss and the Senior Management
yes of course they have to take some of
the big decisions the Strategic ones
you wouldn't have them taking every
decision would you
standing over your shoulder telling you
exactly how to use a robot arm
getting them to write the code for
computer-aided manufacturing of course
not
nothing will get done
big decisions will get put off because
you wouldn't be able to see the wood for
the trees
while other decisions taken by the wrong
people not close enough to the action
would get botched
yet this is exactly how we try to run
Britain
it's why for all the talk of leveling up
nothing ever happens
it's just that old game of passionately
identifying a problem
rather than facing the real solution and
accepting Westminster must give power
away
well no more no more sticking plaster
politics no more Westminster hoarding
power no more holding back this
country's economic potential
this year we're going to show how real
change comes from Unlocking The Pride
and purpose of British communities
and
there are two steps to this
first we will modernize central
government so it becomes Dynamic agile
strong and above all focused
driven by clear measurable objectives
National missions a new approach to the
power of government more strategic more
relaxed about bringing the expertise of
public and private business and Union
Town and City
and using that partnership to drive our
country forward
we will announce these missions in the
coming weeks our Manifesto will then be
built around them and they will be the
driving force of the next Labor
government
they will push us onto a better future a
decade of national renewal
[Applause]
clear
none of this should be taken as code for
labor getting its big government
checkbook out
of course investment is required
I can see the damage the tours have done
to our Public Services as plainly as
anyone else
but we won't be able to spend our way
out of their mess it's not as simple as
that
let me give you an example
of our different approach
you start with a mission a plan for a
hundred percent clean power generation
by 2030. that mission Builds on an
opportunity that clean British energy is
nine times cheaper than imported fossil
fuels it's backed by investment public
and private in Wind solar nuclear
hydrogen green steel and carbon capture
it's galvanized by reform by Great
British energy a newly publicly owned
company that will take this opportunity
and turn it into good secure well-paid
British jobs and it's driven by speed
and a long-term Vision that doesn't back
down when the going gets tough
one vested interests take you on over
planning or trying to hold on to fossil
fuels
because if you take action early
if we did this now
then businesses and working people get
cheaper bills forever
our country gets energy independence
from tyrants like Putin forever
and we can give every Community a shot
at the green jobs of the future
that's just one example One mission
but it shows our recipe for taking on
sticking plaster politics it's new
technology Unleashed by private
investment and private Enterprise
tackling a huge social challenge
and then providing a new foundation for
long-term prosperity
which crucially communities can build on
themselves
and this is the second of our two steps
giving communities the chance to control
their economic destiny
the argument is devastatingly simple
the decisions which create wealth in our
communities should be taken by local
people with skin in the game
and a huge power shift out of
Westminster can transform our economy
our politics and our democracy
I'll go back to brexit yes a whole host
of issues were on that ballot paper
but as I went around the country
campaigning for remain
I couldn't disagree with the basic case
so many lead voters made to me
people who wanted Public Services they
could rely on High streets they could be
proud of opportunities for the next
generation and all of this in their town
or their City
it was the same in the Scottish
referendum in 2014.
many of those who voted yes did so for
similar reasons
and it's not an unreasonable demand
it's not unreasonable for us to
recognize the desire of communities to
stand on their own feet
it's what Take Back Control meant
the control people want is control over
their lives and their communities
so we will embrace the Take Back Control
message but we'll turn it from a slogan
into a solution from a catchphrase into
change
we will spread control out of
Westminster
devolve new powers over employment
support transport energy climate change
housing culture Child Care provision and
how councils run their finances and
we'll give communities a new right to
request Powers which go beyond even that
all this will be in a new Take Back
Control Bill a centerpiece of our first
King's Speech
that bill will deliver on the demands
for a New Britain a new approach to
politics and democracy
and your approach to growth and our
economy
2022 killed the Tory idea that it's only
those at the top who grow our economy
2023 will be the year labor shows a new
plan for growth
the year when we accept that if the
southeast races ahead redistribution
can't be the one word plan for the rest
of Britain
that was also part of the brexit moment
working people want their town or city
to prosper by standing on their own feet
they want growth from the Grassroots to
create wealth on their terms and in
their way
so let me spell it out no more shortcuts
strong Dynamic government is necessary
but it's not sufficient
communities need strong public services
but that's not enough on its own
for National renewal there is no
substitute for a robust private sector
creating wealth in every community
you can see this in the Precision
engineers and life scientists in Glasgow
the video game Visionary is in Dundee
the cyber security firms of the valleys
and South Wales the hydrogen Corridor
and T side Nano Manufacturing in
Northern Ireland Ceramics in North
Staffordshire fuel cells in the West
Midlands robotics in Manchester
we need to turbocharge this potential
but Westminster can't do that on its own
it can only do it with communities
that's why labor will give them the
trust
the power
and the control
we won't accept decline
won't write our country off
won't leave Britain in a brace position
buffeted from crisis to crisis holding
on
trying to make it through
that's no way to live
and it's no way to run a country
so this year in place of sticking
plaster politics we'll set out the case
for change the case for New Britain the
case for hope that the country will get
better that politics can be a force for
good that Britain can be run in the
interest of working people
we can feel the public looking at us
again and we won't let up we'll work
every day to earn their trust show them
a new way of governing and lead them to
the fairer Greener more Dynamic Britain
where aspiration is rewarded working
people succeed communities control their
own destiny and where politics doesn't
hide from the big challenges that face
our children thank you very much
thank you
thank you thank you very much
thank you
thank you very much we're now going to
take some questions from the media and I
want to get through quite a few of these
so can I encourage
um all our collection of the media just
to ask one question rather than the
growing habit of two or three or four so
uh I think we're going to start with
Chris Mason from BBC
Chris thank you Chris writing BBC News
you said today that labor won't be
getting its big government's checkbook
out will you match the conservative
spending limits going into the election
well um first Chris that commitment in
relation to the uh checkbook is because
we know that we're going to inherit
inherit
um a badly damaged economy and a badly
damaged country and therefore we have to
be absolutely clear that we can't just
spend our way out of that mess
um obviously we'll set out our case as
we go into the election and we've
already set out our fiscal rules in
terms of spending for day to day only
borrowing to invest and getting debt
down as a percentage of our economy they
will be the rules that we go into but
what I'm trying to set out today is a
different approach and making it
absolutely clear that it's a different
way of working it's about partnership
it's about pushing power away from
Westminster that matters in all of this
but um after 13 years of failure on
every level we know we're going to
inherit a very badly damaged economy and
therefore that is what drives me to say
we will not be getting out that big
government checkbook
everything that we say we will do will
be fully costed and set out as it
already has been and we'll do that going
into the election thank you Chris I've
got Ali from Skye
from sky
now you've criticized what you've seen
that yesterday for being light on policy
but when it comes to the big issues that
are impacting people right now NHS pay
the strikes
what exactly are you going to do to help
people it's not clear what you're saying
Beyond saying that you would do better
job than the Tories you say you're not
willing to get your big checkbook out
but how are you going to fix those
problems help people right now what
difficult decisions are you going to be
willing to make well look Ali I mean
look I have criticized um the Prime
Minister you're absolutely right I
thought his promises were weak and low
ambition
um inflation is the biggest example of
that saying inflation down to the rate
lower than has already predicted is not
a big promise to the British public and
the idea that after 13 years of failure
can come along in the 13th year and say
I've got five new promises please give
us one more chance I just feel is so far
removed from reality but in relation to
your question obviously the things we
need to do this winter to get us through
and we've argued the case for
discharging patients more quickly
virtual Wards there are many things
we're making use of facility it is but
what we can't do and this is really the
centerpiece of what I'm trying to say is
every year we go into an NHS crisis it
just gets worse and worse and worse and
so we're in the worst one ever now and
that's sticking plaster politics we can
do something this year to get through
but if we don't actually understand the
fundamentals of change we'll be back in
the same crisis next year and the year
after and Central to that is the
workforce and that's why we've said that
we will have a fully funded plan to
bring in you know thousands and
thousands more nurses more doctors
Etc more medical staff coming into the
NHS because in the end that's the only
way we're going to get out of this that
long you know putting another sticking
plaster on is necessary of course it is
it's a bit like the energy and cost of
living crisis we've got to do it for the
one more winter but if we don't tackle
the fundamentals we'll be back in this
cycle next year and the year after the
year after and that's what's been one of
the biggest failures of politics in the
last 13 years thank you Ali Gary
given Channel 4 News
um
it doesn't sound like you do want to
Splash the cash so beyond yours or
costed extra investment and things like
the NHS you are going to be looking for
more from the same money or more from
less even sometimes in public services
can I ask you about one specific area of
that
Tony Blair looked to the private sector
to help with that kind of efficiency
saving
do you think there's more scope for the
private sector delivering Public
Services have we reached the outer
limits of it is it sometimes what works
could there be a whole new development
in that uh under your Premiership well
Gary uh thank you for that question the
the way I see it is this that
um
if a party wins an election and sets out
its stall it's programmed for change
it's then got to answer the question
well how are you going to deliver that
um and there are three basic models one
is
you suck it all up to the center and try
to deliver it all
um through the state I don't think that
works and we won't be doing that to be
clear
um the other is to say well we've set
out what we want to achieve but um it's
the market that knows best so we'll now
leave it to the market
um I don't believe in that model I don't
think that's worked either and that's
why what I'm proposing today what we've
put on the table is a partnership model
where with the you know an agile active
State working with in partnership with
private business we deliver together
each clear about what their role is in
that partnership and that's the way in
which we deliver for the future but Gary
there's another part to your question
which is really important as well
because I've obviously said
um we're not going to get the big
checkbook out but that is reform having
run a public service for five years I
ran a public service in the criminal
justice sector for five years I've long
been an advocate of Reform and we have
to reform our Public Services whether
that's health or criminal justice
because
um you know the idea that simply putting
more money in which of course is needed
and will bring about some improvement
won't transform our public services in
the way that I think they need to
deliver in the 21st century Gary thank
you for that um Harry from ITV
thank you um
you've said you want to avoid sticking
plaster politics but sometimes immediate
crises require short-term Solutions so
take the strikes this week for example
what would you actually do differently
in your in your negotiations with the
unions you said that you would take them
seriously would you ignore the NHS pay
recommendation would you offer more than
five percent you said you want offer 19
but would you offer more than what's
already been offered at the moment look
Harry firstly I think it's very
important
in relation to Industrial action to
understand quite how much people are
struggling to make ends meet and why
they're driven to this action
particularly the nurses never been on
strike nationally ever before now I
don't want to see these strikes I don't
think there's any nurse certainly that
I've spoken to or heard of Who Wants to
be on strike on the contrary before they
went on strike in those final days they
said to the government just come in the
room with us and talk to us and we won't
go on strike and the government refused
so I would get in the room I would talk
to them
and talk to them and there's going to
have to be compromised and I also ask
Harry this
the government hasn't got a strategy
what's he going to do
will it go in the room in a few weeks
time
and reach an agreement that they could
have reached before the strike started
and then watch everything that's
happened in the last few weeks happen
all that distress to people
by doing agreements sometime down the
line in a few weeks is that their
strategy
or will they just Slug It Out month
after month after month in a war with
our nurses
I think we're entitled to say they clear
have got no strategy whatsoever for
dealing with these strikes particularly
the nurses strikes thank you Harry and
Lucy from times
hi Lucy Fisher from times radio
um we know that the government are
shortly expected to bring forward
anti-strike legislation you've made
clear that you think those laws are
wrong will you commit to repealing them
if labor come into government and do you
think any new measures are needed to
ensure minimum service levels for the
public in crucial sectors like health
and rail Lucy look um firstly
frankly the government is all over the
show on this every day there's a
different briefing as to where there's
going to be legislation what's going to
be when it's going to come and I think
there's a reason for that and that's
because I don't think this legislation
is going to work and I'm pretty sure
they've had an assessment that tells
them uh that it's likely to make a bad
situation worse and so in answer to your
question obviously
um you know we'll look at what they
bring forward but if it's further
restrictions then we repeal it
um and the reason for that is I do not
think that legislation is the way that
you bring an end to Industrial disputes
you have to get in the room and
compromise you can't legislate your way
out of 30 years 13 years of failure so
let's say the government's all over the
show will we repeal it yes we will thank
you Lucy uh Kieran from the guardian
Karen Stacy from the guardian hi
um you talk about nurses at the moment
the government appears to be budgeting
for a two percent pay rise for nurses in
2023 2024 you've said 19 is too much
will you at least say that two percent
is too little if that is what ends up
being the offer well Karen let's wait
and see what the government actually
um brings forward because
um there's been a lot of speculation
um and I'm not going to stand here
before the start of those negotiations
say what the right percentage is neither
the Health Service nor the Unions would
expect me
um to do that but what I do expect is
the government to go into the room and
compromise and talk to the nurses all
they're asking is for the government to
get in the room I think many people
watching this or just looking on in
politics and seeing nurses on strike for
the first time
would stand or watch in disbelief all
the nurses are saying is come into the
room and talk to us and we won't be on
strike
and the government won't do it and I
think that's the central reason that
we're stuck in this situation uh Henry
times
Andrew Zeppelin from the times um if you
are restraining spending now no longer
getting out the big government checkbook
do you still stand by the policy of
abolishing University tuition fees well
look I mean uh University tuition fees
um are not working well they burden
young people going forward obviously
we've got a number of propositions in
relation to those fees that we will put
forward as we go into the election but
you know I have to be honest about it
the damage that's been done to our
economy means that we are going to have
to and we know we will cost everything
as we go into that election and we will
do that with discipline as we've done it
so far so I'm not going to spell out our
Manifesto in a France in advance Henry
you know I won't do that you don't
expect me to do that but I can say that
every commitment we made will be
absolutely fully funded that's a cast
iron guarantee as we go into that
election
um Jack from the Sun
usual New Year's message to try and
Champion uh brexit voters like never
before even announcing a Take Back
Control Bill many of them will remember
you advocating for a second referendum
do you now regret that and why should
they now believe you well Jack
um even in those turbulent years 2016 to
2019 I was always making the argument
that there was always
um something very important sitting
behind that lead vote that phrase Take
Back Control
was really powerful it was like a
Heineken phrase it got into people and
the more they asked themselves do I have
enough control the more they answer that
question no and if you can't make ends
meet in your family you don't have
control if you don't have a secure job
you don't have control if you feel you
can't go out after dark because of
anti-social Behavior you don't have
control but I've always accepted that
argument that's why I said in my speech
that you can't deny the basic arguments
being made and I think it's time for us
to embrace it when how many years on
from that referendum and that change has
never happened
um and we intend as I say to turn that
slogan into a solution and to bring
forward that bill a Take Back Control
Bill to deliver it in action thank you
Jack uh Lizzy from the mirror
hi dear um Mark Drakeford recently said
that he put the Welsh labor was readying
for a snap election Because he believes
that the government could be on the
brink of collapse are you doing the same
uh Lizzy I in the autumn
party on an election footing so I
reorganized our teams I went through
everything we need to do to be election
ready because
um back then I thought the government
could fall at any time
um and we need to be ready if it falls
at any time and
um I've also I've always seen my task as
labor leader I started in April 2020.
um the labor party was flat down on the
floor my job was to change the labor
party to recognize if you lose that
badly you don't look at the electorate
and say what were you doing you've
changed your party
to demonstrate that the government was
unfit to govern and then to lay out the
alternative case and we've been sticking
to those tasks and we are now ready for
an election
um and I put the party on that basis
sometime ago I mean as to when the
election will be your guess is as good
as mine I think it should be straight
away I think after after 13 years of
failure 13 years of failure on our
economy growing the economy has been you
know far far too slow over the last 13
years our public services are on their
knees they've done huge damage last
Autumn to our economy
um and you know I think people are
entitled to say we don't want any more
of this we should have a general
election as soon as possible thank you
Lizzy uh Camilla from the telegraph
Camilla
um thank you um you're giving a speech
in the same venue as the Prime Minister
did yesterday you're both I know you we
booked it first
but it's a great venue
um you're both promising competence
economic stability and optimism
um you both appear to be battling for
the center ground how can you explain to
voters what is the real difference
between the two of you oh just look at
the last 13 years how can you seriously
come along
after 13 years of low growth 13 years of
Public Services being you know pushed to
their knees 13 years of you know
quashing aspirations of many people
across the country
um you know nobody really disputes that
our country is in a real state but it's
in a real mess
are to come along 13 years along the
line and say well I mean the Prime
Minister yesterday
it was almost as if it sort of suddenly
arrived from the Moon I was looking
around saying everything's busted
nothing working there was a real
commentary thing is there's a bit in
this speech where it says you know NHS
not working education not working
economy not working yeah and you've been
in bar for 13 years
um so that is the fundamental decision
no good coming along and making five
Bland promises and saying well just give
us another chance I'm sorry about the
last 13 years that's just not going to
wash with the British public
um thank you Camilla David from the
email
thanks very much
um your speech didn't mention
immigration uh particularly the issue of
small boats uh which the PM made a cast
iron Pledge on yesterday
um was it absent from your speech
because you don't have a plan
um and if you do have a plan what is it
well David we do have a plan and we've
set it out before many many times
um and it's a five-point plan but the
two most important as far as I'm
concerned are firstly I don't want
anybody crossing the channel in that way
nobody should want that anybody making
that dangerous Journey
the way to deal with that in my view is
to tackle the criminal gangs Upstream
criminal gangs are running this they're
running people to the Border in North
France and we have to tackle them at
source now when I was director of public
prosecutions we ran joint
um you know across Nation teams to deal
with transport of drugs and guns across
borders we can do it in relation to the
trafficking of people and the movement
of people across borders we can we can
go after those gangs and get them at
source that's the first thing the second
thing David is this
um the appalling delay in processing
Asylum applications
is at the heart of this
four percent of those that cross the
channel in small boats in 2021 have had
their Asylum claims processed
four percent when I first saw that
figure I couldn't believe it and that is
the state of our government and its
ability to grip this has to be measured
against their failure to tackle that
source and their absolute failure with
Asylum applications thank you David and
then Chloe from the eye
thank you
um on the subject of Take Back Control
Lisa and Andy told the eye earlier this
week that labor is looking to align with
EU laws in more areas than just security
and Veterinary standards when are we
going to get the full details of this
proposed new relationship and does this
mean that you're prepared to give up UK
sovereignty in some areas in order to
achieve those close to economic ties
well Chloe um we've set out I set out in
a speech I gave at the Irish Embassy
last year the sort of five principles
that we would apply in terms of
improving our relationship with the EU I
don't think anybody now seriously argues
um that this so-called oven-ready deal
is actually working for anyone and so of
course we have to address that and I'll
set that out in more detail but the five
principles that that'll be based on have
already been set out thank you very much
everybody thank you all for coming this
morning I'm really sorry to those of you
that had to stand who probably wanted me
to give shorter answers just now happy
New Year thank you very much
[Applause]